As infectious disease has declined is
a source of mortality in contemporary
populations.
Chronic diseases have risen in importance
is major causes of mortality and the
two leading chronic diseases that kill
people or cardiovascular disease and
cancer.
Cardiovascular disease is associated
with cholesterol metabolism,
environment,
exercise and diet.
And female reproductive cancers are uh,
something that we do not see so much of
in naturally reproducing populations.
So we will now explore the sense in which
these diseases are mismatched diseases.
Okay.
The female reproductive cancers are
elicited in part by the use of oral
contraceptives, which are a new,
very new cultural innovation.
Yeah.
So first heart and cardiovascular disease
come through atherosclerosis mediated
by cholesterol metabolism.
In this little diagram here,
basically what you can see is a,
an artery and it has in it plaque,
which is building up
here is in cross section.
You can see obstructing about half
the diameter of the artery there.
So atherosclerosis is a
thickening of arterial walls.
It's caused by the
accumulation of macrophages,
lymphocytes and cholesterol in plaques.
So the key ingredients are
initially inflammation and
then macrophages which are
recruited to the inflamed site and the
metabolism of cholesterol at that site.
There are two kinds of lipoproteins,
low density and high density.
The low density lipoproteins,
transport cholesterol from the liver
to other tissues and the high density
lipoproteins transport it from
the tissues back to the liver.
Animals and like us cannot
catabolize cholesterol.
So excess cholesterol is converted to
bile acids in the liver and as Excreta id
through the intestine.
Cholesterol is absolutely essential
for our normal metabolism,
but when it is dysregulated,
when it is out of homeostatic control,
it can produce disease.
Normal cells turn down the LDL,
the low density lipoprotein receptors
when they have enough cholesterol.
Inflammation produces oxidized LDLs that
both promote further inflammation and
are taken up by scavenger
receptors in macrophages.
So the scavenger receptors
are not downregulated.
When cholesterol concentrations rise and
they continue to take off oxidized LDLs,
this then produces more inflammation.
It increases the recruitment
of macrophages to the uh, in,
in arteries to the arterial intima.
It increases the permeability of blood
vessels and it does increase his access
to low density lipoproteins in the blood.
This is a positive feedback loop and it
can operate at low levels for many years
producing larger and larger
athletic atherosclerotic plaque.
It is a feedback loop
that actually is designed,
is part of our defense
and tissue repair system,
so it is one of the vulnerabilities
of our defense system.
Yeah.
When plaques get large enough,
they produce clotting,
rupture myocardial infarction or stroke.
Yeah.
Now Environment,
exercise and diet can all
ameliorate these issues.
Physical inactivity, poor
diet, obesity, drinking,
smoking and emotional stress,
increase LDL and lower HDLs in the
blood and thereby increased risk of
cardiovascular disease.
Moderate exercise increases high density
lipoproteins and lowers blood pressure
a diet rich in unsaturated fats also
increases high density lipoproteins too
much alcohol and the other hand damages
the livers ability to regulate these
levels of lipoproteins and smoking
damages the liver and it also inflames
arterial walls.
Emotional stress increases blood pressure,
it increases adrenaline secretion and
cardiovascular diseases also have a
genetic component largely expressed
through environmental interactions of this
nature.
So cardiovascular disease is a set of
mismatched diseases caused by sedentary
lifestyles,
diets rich in processed fats and sugars
and exposure to alcohol and nicotine.
Yeah.
What about female reproductive cancers?
We can learn something
there by contrasting our
contemporary populations with
naturally reproducing populations.
As we've seen,
cancers are produced by mutations and
mutations occur when cells divide and
cells divide in breasts and ovaries.
During every menstrual cycle.
Hunter gatherer females were pregnant or
lactating for much more of their lives
than our women in post
industrial societies.
As a result,
they could expect about 150
menstrual cycles per lifetime,
whereas a postindustrial woman can expect
to have 350 to 400 menstrual cycles
per lifetime.
That implies about three times the risk
of reproductive and cells that divide
during menstrual cycles.
Yeah.
Well, obesity also increases the risk of
reproductive cancers because fat cells
release estrogen and in Post
Menopausal American women,
obesity increases the risk
of breast cancer 2.5 times
as compared with women who
are not obese.
So female reproductive cancers do have
an association with oral contraceptives,
but it's complex and nuanced.
Yeah.
Women who use oral contraceptives to have
more of a menstrual cycles than women
who are experiencing natural fertility.
Yeah.
However, the impact of oral
contraception is complicated.
Okay.
The use of oral contraceptives does
increase the risk of breast cancer,
but at the same time,
it decreases the risk of ovarian cancer.
The effects roughly cancel out with
little net change in cancer risk.
So to summarize,
the cardiovascular diseases are mismatched
diseases that have multiple causation
mediated by inflammation,
macrophages and cholesterol.
The risk factors are physical inactivity,
poor diet, obesity, drinking, smoking,
and emotional stress,
all of which contribute to the growth of
arterial plaque who's rupture then can
cause myocardial infarct or stroke.
The risk of a female reproductive cancer
is affected both by oral contraception
in by obesity.
Women are now experiencing many more
menstrual cycles per lifetime than they
used to, and the fat cells of
obese women also secrete estrogen,
both cause cells in breast and
ovaries to divide. However,
oral contraception has opposite effects
on the risks of breast and ovarian
cancer effects that roughly
cancel each other out.